لا تتردد في شرب الكثير من الماء ، من
الجيد دائمًا أن تظل رطبًا ،
ولكن بالنسبة لفكرة أن
شرب المزيد من الماء سوف
يطرد فيروس كورونا من نظامك ، فإننا لا
نعرف ما إذا كان طريق البراز الفموي هو
وسيلة انتقال مهمة ولكن الماء
سوف  عدم طرد الفيروس من النظام ،
فإن فكرة أن شرب المزيد من الماء
سيطرد فيروس كورونا من نظامك هي
واحدة من عدة أساطير حول الفيروس
تنتشر على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الأساطير التي
يتوق الخبراء إلى تبديد
أسطورة بارزة أخرى مفادها أنك إذا
حبست أنفاسك للمزيد  أكثر من 10 ثوانٍ دون
سعال أو إزعاج ، ليس لديك
تليف ، علامة على وجود عدوى في
الرئتين تحبس أنفاسك لمدة 10
ثوانٍ نوع من
التليف البارومتر في رئتيك يتسبب في تندب
في أنسجة الرئة ولا
يوجد أي مقياس ضغط مثل  مرة أخرى إذا
كان
لديك أي ضيق في التنفس إذا كان لديك أي ضيق في التنفس إذا كنت تعاني
من الحمى إذا كان لديك أي من
أعراض الجهاز التنفسي ، فأنت بحاجة إلى انتقاذك.
p الهاتف والاتصال بمقدم الرعاية
الطبية وإخبارهم ما هي هذه الأعراض التي هي
خرافة أخرى مفادها أن الشباب
والأطفال لا يمكنهم الإصابة بفيروس كورونا نحن نعلم
أن الأطفال والمراهقين نعم
يمكنهم بالفعل الإصابة بفيروس كورونا هذا
ولكن لأسباب لا نفهمها
لا يبدو أنهم يمرضون مثل
الأفراد الأكبر سنًا أو أولئك الذين يعانون من
الوهن ، لكن الخبراء يقولون إن الأطفال
والمراهقين هم أيضًا
ناقلون محتملون لفيروس كورونا ، وهناك
فكرة شائعة أخرى تدور حول
أن الطقس الأكثر دفئًا
سيؤدي إما إلى انحسار الفيروس أو زواله.
يقول الخبراء الخارجيون
إن هناك تفشيًا سابقًا للفيروس بلغ ذروته في
الشتاء ثم انخفض ، لكنهم يقولون إنه مع
فيروس كورونا لم نمر
لمدة عام كامل حتى الآن ، لذلك لا نعرف ما إذا
كان الطقس الصيفي سيساعد  الاعتماد
على درجة الحرارة أو الرطوبة لتعطيل
أو علاج هذا الفيروس بالطريقة التي تقتل
بها وتعطيل هذا الفيروس عن طريق
التنظيف
والتطهير المناسبين.  هناك أسطورة مفادها أن فيروس كورونا
يمكن أن ينتقل من خلال خبراء البريد ،
ويقولون بالحكم من خلال فيروسات مماثلة سابقة ،
إنهم لا يبقون على قيد الحياة لفترة طويلة
على الأسطح أو الأشياء ، فإن احتمالية
خطر الإصابة بالفيروس من البريد
منخفضة جدًا ، تذكر ، خاصةً الكثير
من  يتم إرسال البريد
عن طريق الطائرات التي تخضع لظروف قاسية جدًا ،
ولكن إذا كانت لديك أي شكوك
، فلا ضرر من مسح هذه
العبوة أولاً باستخدام مناديل Clorox أو
مناديل كحولية ، وهذا سيضمن
أن فتحها آمن ،
فهذه المشكلة لا تزال تخبرنا
بعدم  لمس وجهنا ولكن من الصعب حقًا
ألا تثق في لمس وجهك الذي
تعتقد أنه مرتبط بذلك ، فلماذا
يحدث ذلك كثيرًا في
لحظات مرهقة في الواقع في دراستين بحثيتين منفصلتين
بيننا نلمس وجهنا على
ما يبدو بين 16 و 23 مرة
فكر في الأمر بهذه الطريقة كل ساعة هناك الكثير
من النهايات العصبية في أنفنا أو أعيننا أو
فمنا.
جزيئات eep تأتي في
أشياء خطيرة في آذاننا
أنفنا بالطبع لدينا رموش
وحواجب لمنع دخول الحطام إلى
أجسامنا وبالتالي يمكن للحطام أن يسبب
الحكة وعندما يُطلب منا عدم لمس
وجهنا أصبحنا متساويين  أكثر وعياً
بهذه العاهرة ، لذلك نحن نشاهدها في كثير من الأحيان ،
نعم أفعل ذلك بيديك لأنه
يمنحك تلك اللحظة للتفكير
فيما تفعله معهم قبل أن
تتفاعل مع شيء ما لدى
معظم الأشخاص المصابين
بفيروس كورونا الجديد
"  تبدأ أعراض الاحتضار مثل
الأنفلونزا مع حمى السعال وضيق
التنفس ومعظم أجهزة المناعة لدى الأشخاص الأصحاء
قادرة على محاربة الفيروس
ولكن المرض يمكن أن يكون مميتًا للأشخاص
الذين لديهم ضعف في جهاز المناعة مثل
كبار السن وأولئك الذين يعانون من وجود سابق.
الحالات الطبية مثل أمراض القلب
والسكري وأمراض الرئة
تواجه أجسامهم صعوبة أكبر في مكافحة الفيروس ،
هذه هي الطرق التي يمكن بها لـ Kovat 19 أن يتحول إلى
الالتهاب الرئوي القاتل Kovat 19 هو مرض تنفسي
يعني  يبدأ وينتهي عادة
في الرئتين المصابة
بسائل مما يجعل
التنفس صعبًا لذلك لا يمكن للأكسجين الوصول إلى
بقية الجسم مما قد يؤدي إلى
تعفن الدم وقد يتسبب القتال بين الفيروس
والجهاز المناعي في حدوث أضرار جانبية
يحدث الإنتان في جميع أنحاء الجسم
عندما يتفاعل جسمك بشكل أساسي مع
عدوى
يمكن أن تسبب هذه الاستجابة المناعية الخارجة عن السيطرة ضررًا أكثر
مما تنفع وينتهي في النهاية بفشل الأعضاء
والموت ، اتصل بطبيبك على
الفور إذا كنت تعاني من أي
أعراض لكوفات 19 وأنت  ربما
تعرضت للفيروس